Elon Musk at 330 billion dollars was the
richest man in the world
then Tesla's stock has plummeted more
than 65 percent since the start of 2022.
he's no longer the world's richest man
and his EV company is on track for
having its worst year in the stocks
history by the end of 2022 musk lost
more than half his net worth on paper on
any given day he could be the world's
richest man or he could be the world's
second richest man or you know he might
fall because the Share value of Tesla
Falls most of musk's wealth is tied up
in shares of his businesses that means
volatility in his Company's stock and
valuations can directly sway his net
worth
in the last few months musk has
recovered some lost ground his net worth
according to the Bloomberg billionaire
index is now estimated at about 160
billion dollars but the trajectory of
his key businesses has some investors
concerned
here's how a volatile stretch for some
of his companies is impacting musk's net
worth
Elon musk's wealth really ballooned
during the pandemic but in the past year
so we've seen it go on a kind of a wild
roller coaster The Wall Street Journal
reached out to Elon Musk for comment but
he did not respond since he took over
Twitter roughly six months ago there's
been lots of questions about his overall
management style and wondering if you
know perhaps some of the magic has been
rubbed off musk is a Serial entrepreneur
he made 22 million dollars selling his
first startup in 1999. an internet
business called zip2 then bet most of
that money on a startup PayPal when eBay
bought PayPal he made 165 million
dollars and used that to found SpaceX
and become an early investor in Tesla he
bought Twitter in October 2022 for 44
billion dollars funding some of the
purchase by selling 39 billion dollars
worth of his Tesla shares
been a rocky few months since his
takeover Twitter's never been a company
that's made a lot of money oftentimes
being unprofitable on an annual basis
but he takes control and immediately he
says he needed to start making dramatic
changes soon after the perch address
musk fired top Executives laid off
thousands of employees and said
advertisers cutting ad spending had led
to a massive drop in Revenue he thinks
he's in essence right size the ship but
now it's a private company so we don't
know exactly what's going on in there
musk's Ambitions for Twitter are a mix
of content communication and commerce
similar to popular Chinese social media
platform WeChat all this musk says will
help turn Twitter into a company worth
250 billion dollars but for now Twitter
is valued around 20 billion and I
remember 20 billion dollars is
dramatically less than what he acquired
the company for and the deal that was
around 44 billion dollars so just
imagine his wealth going like this and
it's just been a wild ride to watch
Elon musk's main source of wealth is
Tesla as of late April 2023 Tesla was
worth about 500 billion dollars and musk
owns about 13 of the company Tesla grew
significantly in 2020. up to a peak
value of 1.2 trillion dollars in 2021
but it fell significantly last year down
to around 390 billion and all that
fluctuation has affected musk's personal
wealth while Tesla's stock has rebounded
slightly in 2023 investors have a few
concerns the amount of time musk spends
focused on Twitter and Tesla's price
cuts that have reduced profit margins on
each car itself well Tesla is profitable
and it's projecting a dramatic growth
into the future the question is how
dramatic and how profitable musk also
envisions a future where Tesla's
continue making money for the company
after someone initially purchases the
car for example charging for software
update States and that's a big bet
that's a in a lot of ways an industry up
ending business model
Tesla has not yet shown the ability to
deploy fully autonomous vehicle
technology and so he's essentially
telling the world uh this is coming and
we're going to make a lot of money down
the road and wall Street's not so sure
about that
and then there's SpaceX
musk founded the company in 2002 with
money he got from selling his stake in
PayPal and while SpaceX doesn't release
financials last year the company was
valued at around 140 billion dollars as
of 2022 a trust associated with Elon
Musk owned 42 percent of the company
SpaceX Executives recently said it's
making money off of its Falcon 9 rockets
and dragon spacecraft and Executives
expect starlink a SpaceX division that
provides high-speed broadband internet
with satellites to begin making money
this year too Tesla is where the bulk of
his wealth is at this point but SpaceX
is increasingly looking like it's going
to be a juggernaut onto its own and
might be where the next kind of tranche
of huge valuation comes from
musk also owns three other companies
neuralink boring company and xai they're
all privately held and their finances
are unclear you know they're early
stages you know the bulk of Elon musk's
time at this point is in three places
Tesla SpaceX and now Twitter these other
startups are of interest to him but he
would even say uh that they are far down
on the list of priorities in any given
day musk's wealth has traditionally been
tied up in his businesses and he's been
labeled as a cash poor billionaire
because he has to borrow against his
shares for living expenses one of the
things about Elon is he's become richer
and richer is that it gives him the
wherewithal and the ability to chase
these kind of Big Ideas that he has
whether it's trying to make a Humanity a
multi-planetary species or make electric
cars cool or buy that shiny object that
he now has which is Twitter a stumble
now could kind of change his legacy it
could perhaps overshadow his past
accomplishments yet he's still showing a
huge appetite for risk
foreign
[Applause]